the lead MMA analyst for Showtime boxing
as well as the man who does the big
brown breakdown podcast why do you do
that Brendan Schaub it's very difficult
for me to say that over and over again
I know but good to have you here sir yes
I can you good to have you here but I
think um okay first and foremost what do
we make of the eight ounce gloves that
is the news headline du jour of McGregor
Mayweather yeah well tension about this
is you know Mayweather says a lot of
stuff and it's all kind of smoking
mayor's built the fight you know it's
good for you know kind of highlighting
certain stuff and but mostly can't come
to fruition these eight ounce gloves if
the Commission I don't think eyes one of
us before but the Commission agrees upon
it yep and Mayweather encounter both
agree they can actually do it
because before you know it can actually
they can do it if the Commission grants
and that just to the eight ounce gloves
but they both have to agree on it what's
interesting though is usually you can't
find a talents clubs unless you're under
hundred forty seven pounds
I think it's favors Connor in a drastic
way I you know I tip my hat to Floyd cuz
he's putting all the chips you know in
college you know give him as much kind
of favoritism as you can because they
dance clothes for Conor I mean listen if
the fight ends early its can because
Connor lands a huge left hand boy
Mayweather is not knocking Connor out
that's not this is not what he does so
with eight ounce gloves it gives you
know the power even more so on counter
side why for those who need the help
what why would eight ounce gloves be
better than ten ounce gloves wouldn't it
wouldn't it be wouldn't a heavier glove
pack a better wallop that that lands if
he lands that left hand that could end
the fight come on so that's a fair
question but no so like in the UFC we
wear four ounce gloves and that's why
the margin V are so small it's why
there's so many more finishes in boxing
heavyweights where ten ounce gloves you
know so it's not that much of a
difference with that ten ounces it can
give you a little more protection but
the biggest thing is in with defense to
you have more padding to absorb the
punches well what you would definitely
need for with Floyd Mayweather if you're
fighting against him right you need more
because that that's that's the way that
Floyd makes you fight right it did well
he's not going to mix it up with you
well he's talking lately in his
interviews who knows
just trying to sell tickets to and Pam
good job of it but he's saying how you
can come forward and pressure Connor
which you know again I think that favors
comma in this fight
brendan job here on the Rich Eisen show
so we need to sit back and wait for the
Commission to make their decision is
this something that really is as major
as it sounds it's a big deal yeah I mean
it's a definitely a big deal because you
know if he wants to give Connor every
kind of option to win the fight is
possible here he's doing he's doing
doing good job of it and now the the
concept that this is a freak show from
some people saying that this is this is
a freak show that's being put out there
because there really is nobody to
challenge McGregor in a way that he
needs to be challenged in the Octagon
anymore in Floyd is 40 years old and
there's really nobody else that folks
are going to put their hard-earned money
on to see quite like Floyd I lose all
energy my body when they said I just I
it's ridiculous a freak show would be
Michael Phelps racing a great white
shark
that's a freak show a freak show is
selling me on pickup basketball with
these old times that's three on three
talking about YMCA pickup basketball
that's a freak show a freak show is not
the best mix were mixed martial artists
in the world against the best boxer in
the world that's not a freak show it's
very compelling that's what can be the
biggest period of all time well what
makes you compelling to you seriously
now if you yeah go ahead because I mean
again I mean Conor Connors roots are
from boxing short but he's not able to
use the weapons that has made him his
name so that's not true I beg to differ
that he is able to use those weapons
what makes Conor so special is his
awkward style his movement he and switch
between South fall traditional he has
very a movement that no one can really
mimic so when Floyd Mayweather competes
against Conor McGregor on August 26 I
get under those lights that will be the
first time he's ever seen that style
if Khali goes out he's in a regular
boxing stance he's screwed he's not
going to be a hair stance can be even
more awkward than were already picture
inside the Octagon
so I think for Floyd you have to adapt
to all these different variations that
he's never seen before you don't think
he's getting that in his sparring
session can mimic it because you want to
bring in Bruce Lee and he could do this
that rest in peace Bruce Lee know if he
did
that it would not mimic Connor I'm
telling you man the first time you see
that style is under the lights when it
counts the question is how long he
didn't take Floyd to adapt that style
he's going to I'm not saying he's you
you know for Tekonsha gun there an out
class and in boxing but how long did it
take for you to download that awkward
movement for search winning rounds I say
between four to five rounds now in those
four to five rounds just Connor land
some shots I rich I guarantee you he
does
I guarantee it and that's why this fight
is not a free to brandy shop here in the
Rich Eisen show studio the Showtime
boxing lead MMA analyst big brown
breakdown podcast handful and I know but
I'm going to keep on keeping on with
that because I'm a promotion machine
surfer I guess when they're kind enough
to show up in goat suede as you have
Brendan Schaub here is Joe thank you
back in sixty Seconds we'll take a break
I want to talk about what's going on
with Paulie Malignaggi well I know you
know from the Showtime world and and why
somebody who's paid to spar is upset to
look like somebody who's smart with
somebody essentially that's nekkid okay
he goes you just heard that back in 60
seconds with Brandon shop and said
Brenda job is here on the Rich Eisen
show Showtime boxing lead MMA analyst
who says the McGregor Mayweather fight
is not a freak show and in making a
comparison to show what is a freak show
it sounds like you watched the Michael
Phelps versus the great white shark and
we're very sorely dismantle that town
that would you want that for me I did I
tuned in I want to see what was going on
you did not think he really was gonna
race well Michael a shark dead serious
he's like in the camera goes I've raced
a lot of people my life never great
white on my tags can be sick so I tuned
in he's in the ocean in South Africa
doing all the stuff yeah they sold me
man and there was a computer-generated
shark yeah I thought how can you train
the shark not just turn and eat Michael
Phelps the greatest of all time yes
that's some very valuable chump
that would be in the lane next to him
the tip of the hat the Discovery Channel
you got me no I'll learn from this you
sound pissed Michael felt to better so
Paulie Malignaggi was on the show the
day after he sparred with Conor McGregor
and talked like a guy who is talking up
the guy who is foreign with kind of know
he was he was saying hey look I went 12
rounds with him I'm not gonna really
tell you I used all the language that
that I think Floyd's going to talk could
try to get under his skin and his
stamina is up and then pictures come out
the next day where Pauly's on it on the
canvas and then his face is also all
kind of smushed up because Connors
landing one of those left hands and he
got pissed about those pictures being
coming out and my first thought was like
okay I know that's very prideful sport
and everyone's got an ego but when you
agree to spar with somebody don't you
agree to kind of be the second fiddle in
that regard like if I'm if Denzel
Washington ever asked me to read lines I
hope that happened okay training day too
I mean I guess it's not it's not like
I'm in the same endeavor with with with
Denzel Washington although if you did
see my couple of episodes on The Odd
Couple with the with Matthew Perry
Brockman come on now right I seen them
my CSI white Miami where I played myself
twice and announcer oh no I didn't find
myself I just played announcer they're
here I'm getting my $0.08 check right
now but here to see what I'm saying that
is if they showed a scene where Denzel
crushed me I would you know I'd
understand it you wouldn't go on a PR
tour I guess
the best analogy I can make no I hear
you listen I you know in baseball
there's kind of unspoken rules and
infighting kind of same thing you don't
really you only talk about sparring you
know and Polly wasn't brought in to make
a mockery of anything like that and you
know I just came from Dublin that all my
life comedy shows out there six shows
and you know and I was with the Mack
life who follows Conor does all his
stuff and talking to them you know I
don't know if this is out there so there
you go rich but those photos weren't
supposed to be leaked that was that
originally from a second source and once
it came out [ __ ] seems like I what can
you do you know so yeah listen I love
Paula I love Connor obviously I'm kind
of the middle on this but I think with
Paulie he was under the understanding if
you know probably all he's a great
freaking dude he just uh he's a you know
great guy genuine guy but he thought you
know he talked all that trash six months
ago girl like to be Connor one hand
behind my back is an easy fight for
anybody and then you know Connor brings
in the camp on the Showtime kind of
scrum during the the interviews they go
or you can bring Pauline because yeah I
am why are you bringing to beat him up
that's the only reason
well Paulie just stop that was high he
didn't think Congress being real they
brought the rock Paulie and literally
just to try and beat him up to kind of
make a mockery of and improve a point
you know Connors like a baby elephant he
stored that six months ago and now it's
here those photos got leaked
I think Paulie thought they'd spar than
be boys it didn't happen so you know
paulie's very upset is ego so wouldn't
it though if I'm reading into it here
just looking at it because again we're
waiting for this fight and we're taking
on any sort of morsel of information and
how are we blowing it up right more than
it needs to be but with him upset that
he might not look as good because
McGregor's laying him out shouldn't I be
viewing that to say that Malignaggi
thinks McGregor has no chance to beat
Mayweather
because if McGregor makes him look bad
then or he feels that he's being made to
look bad by McGregor yeah
then this guy isn't up to snuff to beat
Mayweather
isn't that a logical leap no I make here
no I don't think it's that I I think you
know and again of I if you ever have a
fighter in here or if you've had
player and he talks about how good he is
in practice right not very good fighter
no one really talks about that stuff you
know I've been in there with some
big-name guys and I've been knocked down
they've been knocked down it didn't ever
gets leaked you don't talked about what
if it did would you get pissed um again
Congress teams not pushing this are they
you know once one serves out and then
remember Paulie K Mountain goes he went
on kind of PR tour and I love Paulie and
I get it his name's never been bigger
and what he wants to do after this who
knows he's even got great insight on
Showtime but Polly goes remembered and
this is all kind of guy code when Paulie
does he doesn't have knockout power
you know I've been hit by him been hit
by a lot harder guys and then you have
to fly back monday and spar with that
guy everyone sees that any news clip
gets picked up so first kind of playing
team see that goes dude what are you
doing man spar so and then goes does
these interviews talks about my punching
power so I think they were there to
prove a point you don't talk about Fight
Club the first rule of Fight Club
first rule of being a man you don't talk
about practice now I'm talking practice
nice [ __ ] back I like it yeah Brendan
Schaub going full already talking about
practice right very good how impressive
was that John Jones victory over Cormier
do you think man ring rust is not a
thing apparently I thought I thought the
first two rounds John it took a little
bit of time to kind of get his bearings
and get used to the lights and being
back in the action but in that third
round you know knocking out DC with a
head kick you know I always have John's
my pad for pound number one I always do
and I think John's embracing connects a
little bit of the heel roll now before
he's dressed like a social study teacher
talking about Jesus which I like what is
this no I want my John Jones the world
champion little you know I don't want
him in that tight bracket people tell
him how to dress someone I want my
artist a little while now if Jones goes
against Lesnar isn't that a freak show
too
is it why don't you went over these
freak shows is it no it's not it's such
a good fight that's an amazing fight is
amazing fight it's amazing
rich come on man I don't know this is
the thing here why Brock Lesnar right
former heavyweight champion phenomenal
wrestler doing sting WWWE lose my number
but he's doing his thing in WWE thats
all fake but then you
who didn't type that did a freak part
that's a good leather but leather has a
real wrestling pedigree he's a real
actual UFC Heavyweight Champion we beat
Shane Carwin Frank mares you meet a lot
of really tough guys okay so for John to
move from light heavyweight and go fight
Brock Lesnar at heavyweight well the
grace every weeks we've ever seen a
short amount of time all right
that's a legit and also that's a legit
fight and I think John beat them and
beat them pretty pretty easily handles
him
I bet I've seen John spar heavyweights
seen John mop the floor with the guy who
does comedy now who's on Rich Eisen sure
okay who's a heavy weight rating top ten
i big deal I've seen him fight
heavyweights myself Travis Browne
Alistair Overeem like some big and zero
problems so when John goes out goes the
heavyweight division he's gonna clear
clear the division out but what about
somebody you could beat him right here
you know what I'm saying that you can
beat him that's what I'm saying though
everybody's moving into different weight
classes or different different ring
sizes to create something I know like
wouldn't it be great to have somebody in
his weight class try and beat him
wouldn't it be great to have somebody to
people and each she'd beat him already
you've got high not everyone does then
there's this Domeier guy this new guy he
has 70 Twitter followers so it's tough
to get him to fight you know he doesn't
have a following okay he's a Swedish kid
you know Thor Switzerland kid cope
there's just he's beating everyone so
you go what's next also this day and age
everyone still follow the Clara McGregor
model how am I going to get up there how
are we gonna cross over the pop culture
become this megastar
where people are demand to see me well
you go to super fights well the problem
is will the super fight Asian aid an
issue that that the the ultimate step up
for McGregor to reach the fame that he's
gotten fortune is to remove four four
sides to the ring general problem no
best of all time the most men live or T
at 40 IIIi don't Ritter this a freak
show I don't I honestly don't know what
spells and everything that I just blew
it up I don't know if you did no I did
okay I didn't know if guys here but we
have little children we have the same
tactics not time actually yeah I don't
know mine's not made of goat we should
get time sure but the bottom line is I
don't feel nice I don't feel like this
is a freak show but and this may be you
know
pie-in-the-sky because Tiger Woods
didn't have somebody basically there is
Mickelson but there was a five-year
period where there wasn't really
somebody on his level but that would be
like hey I've already mastered golf let
me go take my club and try and do a
completely different sport but using the
same you're wrong rich you're wrong and
you know I love you but it's like it's
like a guy dominating the backstroke and
going down get the back joke you're
still in the pool but you're going to do
the breaststroke now because remember
back Seng is a component of mixed
martial arts
hence mix martial arts we box all the
time so it's nothing new it's not it's
not like he's in uncharted territories
he's been in a boxing ring he's had some
boxing matches you know that he's very
familiar with it and the only reason why
I give counter chanson is is because of
his style that is so unique even for
every guy's they can't figure out
but if Connor got traditional boxing
style if doesn't last one round when you
go to Vegas I'm there on Tuesday we're
working all week that is a long time in
Las Vegas Nevada right dude I'm telling
you man I'm not a fan when I'm look I'm
a fan I in Las Vegas Nevada okay
I'm a fan with a capital F a n but I've
got to be there 48 hours and out that's
it I'm time one day five
yeah 36 36 an hour 38 36 hours and out
no no I'm 184 now you got a couple of
meals if you do it I'll tell is we need
to do it right if we do it right if
collar wins this we're going sizzler in
Vegas the three of us and sizzler and
islets okay you know that's just I'm not
taking the actual sizzler
oh yeah no look hey come on we'll do a
gentlemen okay like gentlemen all right
put a tie on reg no I leave we'll get
you really goat I practice and are you
gonna go tux
are you tuxedo for the I got custom
suits for this
they don't say fu on it like honor but
they're nice cuz you wear something like
that that was an impressive suit ah
because the people are making my suits
are similar but I've never get a few on
it where do you wear that can you
imagine if I came on there and you just
like that shirts way too intense like
what are we gonna do that I can't
I would never met in the middle and it's
it's a curse word free goat suede gasps
situation you have the goat cuffs
but whatever and again I'm stunned that
that was not off the rack
that McGregor pinched me I know right
and usually there that it's custom-made
they're selling hundreds of them now
what would be if you're again just to
bring this full circle if you were
playing as a sport in uniform and your
nickname would be what on the back would
you put my nickname here would you put
all odds like in that same three
basketball league no no no no no are you
saying if I'm putting it in baseball
major league Bailey's all eyes in the
back of our judges Jersey really coming
in a couple weeks
taking the pinstripes off to do it too
my heart hurts
that's right that's when you come out
here I love it when the Broncos were all
orange well no I said I like when the
Padres were the camo okay all right Dan
yeah but it will not likely it's not
like the Padres have been in the same
uniform since 1902 when they were the
high rules
wow they're didn't it seems yes I'm out
you know what that's like making a
superfight in baseball it's a bummer
that's right that's a freak [ __ ] you
have to do it don't you for rating
brannad job here on the Rich Eisen show
lots of fun come back let's chat listen
to it okay
Brandon shabbos here 844 204 which
number to Don we'll take your phone
calls give an update on what's going on
in the PGA Championship as well Mike
Pereira former head of NFL reps our
three coming the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to